No yeah you are in Caucasian sure you
have established that right
hey guys I'm Ryan right we're gonna call
her key yeah since we're friends here
katie is new to the channel I met her at
a bar and she begged to come on this
channel pretty self-explanatory happens
all the time now we got introduced to a
mutual friend who started the slinger
app yeah she has a YouTube channel too
does a lot of comedy skits make sure to
check that out so I thought what better
what better what better video to bring
her on for than Judd Apatow's new film
trainwreck yeah she didn't know that was
coming she didn't know I was coming
Judd habits of human we're at the towel
or I don't give a [ __ ] how you pronounce
it strong sexual content nudity language
drug yeah I didn't understand that we're
at the time now exactly what he was
talking about Saturday I wouldn't love
it if you were like I can't do that it
was like you know
does he teach computer and church
basement don't threaten just because you
don't understand the concept of marriage
you dressing like that's nobody else
last week
shut up before you judge you should know
I'm doing fine
my friends are awesome my apartments
sick I have a great job and men's
magazine oh yeah but you're not too
brainy pretty ish and gorgeous you're
approachable
I need a profile I'm a sports doctor
sorry in a row watching Downton Abbey
later about Undine in there dude listen
I'm watching it tonight because I'm not
gonna go to practice and all the guys
are talking about it and I'm left out
all these all sports sports and love
them you're 15 you're Lando epic two
rapes three max tell me
just obey me I think you better know my
fingers
I was they had a really good time last
night I was wanting to want it - yeah oh
she wrote the film that means that she's
smart she is smart that's awesome that's
kind of like what happened with
bridesmaids Kristen Wigg interested to
see a Jenner a fat cell phone cuz it
from my understanding he writes in
directs every film he's ever done except
for this one there's the first one he's
just right there he had faith in it yeah
actually it actually looks like a solid
script like Judd Apatow films tend to
drag on no this is tight yes hey as far
as train wrecks go tight train wreck
that's a category that's why I
discovered acid Akira we can you know
each other the opening was so planning
the town and I loved the way it was shot
to kind of like that eight millimeter
type of camera okay cameras that well
that's it looks like film yes yeah I'm
just trying to sound smart cool cool
those girls were really committed to
that bit I don't think these are good
habits they probably don't know what the
word unrealistic yeah that's true they
had to learn that word and I think it's
an interesting subject to touch on
because he does a lot of movies that
involve like couples I think it's a
really interesting subject on because we
do live in a day and age where it is a
big debate yeah I know girls like that
those are my friends and possibly me at
one time but that's what makes it so fun
is that we get to watch other people's
like such a mess because it does mess
with the psyche I think because there
are times where you're like oh I do want
marriage but you can't be monogamous
like you do it biologically doesn't make
sense or something that's what's
interesting to me about it I don't know
how this film will actually end right I
like that - it doesn't seem like oh we
know for sure that they're gonna get
together for all we know the kind of
person that she is might just not be
able to accept this that she wants to be
like solo
or it's not a deep comedy at all and
it's just gonna be a this is all
speculation at this point yeah
what I love about casting someone like
Amy Schumer Schumer we were I forgot
Amy she doesn't have the traditional
like leading actress look kind of like
Kristen Wiig didn't have that I'm not
saying she's ugly she's relatable she's
she could be anybody she's relatable
because she's not the goddess I don't
want to sound like I'm talking down Sue
might be a goddess in the end of the
movie though she might be and some
people she might be a goddess I think
she's just representing what we all
think about or all of us girls think
about on the inside you know it's like
if a guy starts actually showing
interest or like what nope nope too fast
too gross
too quick yeah that was my life for a
solid 23 years being this skeeved out
Lenore this fever I was either pushed
away or if you ever want to know how to
get into the friend zone I'm your guy
okay I know how my girlfriend took me
ten years together and I finally got so
yeah friendzone I'm your guy just call
me it is from a woman's perspective
because a lot of the time in a role like
this usually you might see it from a
male perspective but to see it
genuine portrayal of a woman it makes it
that much more entertaining to watch the
actresses are great and harder to judge
thing you do I trust you yeah okay
coming from a guy perspective it would
have been like ooh she's made me kind of
[ __ ] yeah you know but then we get to
see it from the girl's perspective and
you're like okay she's a hot mess she
loves to get around she's had intimacy
issues they're like a lot there's a lot
happening and then she meets this one
guy no it looks like an intelligent
comedy like it looks like an intelligent
Authority this guy's
raunchy sex package yeah like even with
judd apatow you like it's usually is
like a bunch of dick jokes but I don't
really feel that from this trailer and
in fact we got very little of him in
this trailer and yet such know what
you're saying like a lot of people will
you know there's that age-old discussion
of how come men can sleep with how many
ever they want but women they did yet
their [ __ ] ORS because it's true Katie
that is what it is that's just a
definite fire all it's written in
Scripture
I liked her other friends who was on the
phone with her because it was like she
seemed super well put together she's in
the office and she's still like no don't
pick it up don't and she didn't seem
like a mess she seems like it's totally
like grounded girl who was just in the
world of dating I love how that friend
is not like telling her oh she's that
friend who they placed there in the
script to say the exact opposite of what
she believed no she's encouraging all
right guys well thanks for talking that
trailer was out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you check out Katie's channel
three principles doesn't let us sketch
comedy on there it's some funny [ __ ]
wouldn't I brought her on if her channel
sucked just saying that check it out
check it out Hades needed the shoutouts
so here we go Callum Garrett
hey can I get a shout-out I [ __ ] that
Trek's too but it was mistaken it was
your mom I don't get the joke tell what
I did gather it is that he's saying he
[ __ ] my mom my mom your mom my mom
what were you kind Hurley's did you buy
her flowers did you get her some
chocolate oh no do you want me to just
kind of if you did that man you did it
that way
groovy [ __ ] that's not the shout
outs Jacoby knocks hey Ryan can I please
have a shout-out I'm a fan and I'm black
yes more black fans working on it I'm
trying to appeal to the black
demographic to show I am NOT a racist
next the gay community shown that
homophobic I think we should get a game
black president one day just putting it
out there and so yeah I can get my gang
to also watch your channel see and
Alyssa's breasts are I'm normally small
just Joe because Alyssa has huge
knockers and you know black guys love
them titties this is my black guy boss
apparently I would love for you to tell
your a game that I don't know if he
meant that like oh these are just my
friends I don't want to be racist but
yeah gang I mean is it safe to assume he
might be an actual gangsters who watch
YouTube like real gangsters who sit
around the computer watching trailer
reaction thank you for your comments
Brock is the best president we've ever
had just saying that Jacoby I agree just
say Obama mouse everyone's better